you ready go for it
yes sir we'll kill the ultimate forged
in fire match-up you are the forest and
fire Champion two Champion plays in a
deadly weapon Showdown it will kill 20
blades 20 Champions you decide the
winner forged in fire Madness
[Music]
this is byhander
my name is Jay replogle ever since I was
a kid Kung Fu Fighting my brother you
know with sticks in the backyard I've
always had a fascination with knives and
bladesmith things is just the mature
level of that I guess
this by hander which means two-hander in
German was a massive sword wielded by
Swiss and German mercenary armies in the
16th century sometimes stretching to
over six feet in length this by-hander
was a long sword featuring an extended
grip in Broad Garden as European armies
employed more Pikes and pole arms on the
battlefield the zweihander emerged as a
counter weapon this enormous sword was
used to break up Pike formations by
cutting spearons and opening up holes in
Enemy Lines due to its size the Spy
hander was only wielded by the biggest
and most audacious soldiers if these
soldiers survived charges into enemy
Spears they would often be paid double
for their substantial risk the zyhander
eventually faded from the battlefield
but survives today in games such as Dark
Souls
the Indian two-handed sword my name is
Jonathan Allen my whole family tends to
be pretty good with their hands my dad
makes a lot of wood furniture and my
brother is actually a welder we always
have taken a lot of pride in doing stuff
with our hands and being creative
emerging around the 17th century this
rare two-handed sword joins some of the
most iconic bladed weapons produced in
the Indian subcontinent The Long
double-edged Blade reached lengths of up
to five feet and was so heavy it
required the wielder to use two hands
for more accurate strikes it also
featured three brass Globes positioned
on the shaft that offered a more secure
grip as well as a counterbalance for the
heavy blade despite its substantial size
the blade was designed to flex by the
mid-18th century improved gunpowder
technology spread throughout India
making the Indian two-handed sword
obsolete
are in Sparta Tennessee at my shop
my game plan is to First do a design and
then we'll just go straight to foraging
this sword is just epic I mean this is
as big as it gets as far as swords go so
it's going to be a real challenge
I've never made anything this big I mean
the overall things would be five feet
it's a physical challenge as much as it
is you know a forging challenge you know
it's like CrossFit forging or something
but clock sticking you got to get it
done
all right
got my grind marks up right here in the
center
it's time to quench
getting an even heat over such a long
piece it's definitely make or break you
know the quench doesn't go good we're
gonna have to start all over
when you have a five foot blade that
means you have to have almost a five
foot quench tank this can be pretty bad
if the quench doesn't go good we're
gonna have to start all over
sweet didn't break
that's what I was hoping for
now I can start working on the guard
I put the wiggle shapes in it so today
I'm going to grab the handle and leather
and it'll makes a super tough handle
that you should be able to take the
impacts string helps everything
nice and tight
this bite is a beast it's going to be
able to take some punishment and deal
some punishment
[Music]
it will connect
first things first I've got a piece of
spring steel that's what I'm going to
use for my blade I'm going to take the
cutting torch cut it down to size and
throw it in the forage and start drawing
out my blade shape
doing it all by hand is tough I didn't
realize it would be quite that tough and
three and a half hours in I'm just
exhausted it's not going like I thought
it would at this point my hands are
locking up I'm shaking it's starting to
wear on me pretty bad
I'm going over that planishing hammer
trying to use it seeing if it'll do
anything to get that steel where I want
it
it's not working out at all so go back
to the Anvil pick up my hammer and just
keep doing what I've been doing all day
last night I was able to get my blade
quench before going home today what I'll
actually do is tweak my handle pieces
one of the Globes cracked
just broke right down the middle
and that's not good
I'm gonna have to try to put it back
together
every time I weld one section another
freaking hole opens up
it's just not going well at all I
finally get my welder dialed in where I
want it to avoid putting any more holes
in it
last night I was able to get a lot more
done than I expected to everything looks
good at this point I definitely want to
do a couple tests of my own
[Music]
[Laughter]
cool
it'll cut it'll chop
hopefully it will kill
Lane Smith's this way hander was a
weapon of War big weapon big damage I
will take your weapon and deliver
killing blows on this ballistic dummy
let's see how much damage your weapon
can do
J up first you ready go for it let's do
this
foreign
it is a heavy weight and it's harder to
manipulate with multiple blows but on
the thrust I was able to go in one side
and all the way
on the opposite side of the dummy
yes sir will kill
like to see what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do we'll take your
sword and deliver caving blows on this
boar carcass Jonathan you ready go for
it
[Music]
foreign
right here first up it's sharp
definitely lacerated through easily when
wielding this weapon there's a nice
balance to it overall your weapons sir
will kill
thank you
gentlemen this is the strength test now
the zweilander was often used against
Pike formations so I'm going to take
yours by handers and go against a rack
of Pikes here five times with each of
your blades see how far it can break
through
Jay you're up are you ready ready
[Music]
wow
when you start swinging this thing it
moves things out of its way
I don't see any damage to your Edge
nicely done thank you gentlemen this is
the dreaded bone chop remember this test
is all about with the bone Studio blades
and not what your blades do to the bones
Jonathan you're up you ready I hope so
good
[Music]
well Jonathan it's a similar result
there is some Edge chipping here as well
the handle being round on one of the
hips did roll in my hand
aside from Edge chipping
held up very well well done thank you
the test the sharpness of your Edge I'm
going to cut into this bundle of sugar
cane twice once with either side
Jay you're up first are you ready as I'm
ever gonna be
it's got a lot of weight to it
but obviously it's plenty Sharp
nicely done thank you to test the
sharpness of your blade I'll be cutting
through these pumpkins we'll take a look
at those cuts see how clean they are
Jonathan you're up are you ready ready
[Music]
nice
so Jonathan you can see your blade has
such a flexibility to it and when it
hits the blade actually warped up cut
over and through
a heck of a cutter actually done thank
you
now it's your turn which weapon will you
choose forged in fire Madness